THE POINT IS TO MAKE YOU MORE
DEPENDENT ON THE VERY PEOPLE WHO
ARE YELLING AT YOU RIGHT NOW ON
CABLE TELEVISION.
THEY ARE THE AUTHORITARIANS.
MARK STEIN JOINS US TONIGHT.
AUTHORITARIANS, IT'S A LITTLE
IRONIC.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CALLING THE
POPULATION THAT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY TRYING TO CONTROL
THE POPULATION BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
>> EXACTLY.
IN FACT, THE REASON THEY WOUND
UP WITH A DONALD TRUMP GETTING
ELECTED PRESIDENT IS BECAUSE
THEY GOT A LONG TRADITION OF
DOING THIS TO ANY REPUBLICAN.
THEY DID IT TO BUSH, THEY DID IT
TO MET ROMNEY, WHO IS A VERY
DEFINITION OF A MILQUETOAST, AND
YET THEY MANAGED TO CLAIM THAT
HE WAS SOME KIND OF BECAUSE HE
DROVE THE DOG TO CANADA OR
WHATEVER HE WAS.
IN THE END, IN THE END, TRUMP
WAS THE ONLY GUY WHO COULD
WITHSTAND THE KIND OF CARELESS
DEMONIZATION THAT GOES ON.
IT'S INTERESTING, YOU GAVE ALL
THOSE EXAMPLES OF THE
AUTHORITARIAN TRENDS ON THE
LEFT.
THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER ONES TOO.
DAVID GERGEN DIDN'T GET UPSET
WHEN SHELDON WHITEHOUSE, A
DEMOCRAT SENATOR, PROPOSE TO
PEOPLE THAT DISAGREE WITH HIS
VIEWS ON CLIMATE CHANGE SHOULD
BE SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
HE DIDN'T WORRY ABOUT THE
AUTHORITARIAN TEMPTATION WHEN
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE
VOTED EFFECTIVELY TO NEUTER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
HE DIDN'T BEMOAN THE TREND
TOWARDS AUTHORITARIANISM WHEN
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
WEAPONIZED BOTH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE IRS TO GO
AFTER ITS IDEOLOGICAL ENEMIES.
WORST OF ALL, HE DIDN'T BEMOAN
THE TREND TOWARDS
AUTHORITARIANISM WHEN DOZENS OF
DEMOCRAT LEGISLATORS, BEFORE
TRUMP HAD EVEN SET FOOT IN THE
OFFICE, DECIDED TO BOYCOTT HIS
INAUGURATION, WHICH IS THE VERY
DEFINING ACT OF A FREE SOCIETY,
THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER.
DAVID GERGEN DIDN'T WHIMPER A
WORD WHEN DOZENS OF DEMOCRATS
DECIDED THEY WERE GOING TO
BOYCOTT THE INAUGURATION.
>> Tucker: HE SEEMED DEEPLY
UNCONCERNED.
I WAS THINKING, WHAT DO ALL
THESE ISSUES HAVE IN COMMON?
GUN CONTROL, MASS IMMIGRATION,
TAX ON A NUCLEAR FAMILY.
THEY NEVER LET UP WITH THAT.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT?
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE FAMILY
IS THE FINAL BORE AGAINST THIS
THREAT OF GOVERNMENT POWER.
WHEN YOU ARE STOPPING LOYALTY TO
YOUR FAMILY FIRST, YOU COULD BE
CONTROLLED.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT ONE OF THE
MOST DISTURBING TRENDS, THERE IS
AN INDIAN PROFESSOR IN BANGALORE
WHO BEMOANS THE WESTERN LEFTISTS
HAVE NATIONALIZED THE FAMILY.
THEY STARTED OFF BY
NATIONALIZING THE MINDS AND CAR
INDUSTRY.
WHEN ALL THAT DIDN'T WORK, THEY
ACTUALLY FIGURED OUT IT'S BEST
JUST TO CUT TO THE CHASE AND
NATURALIZE THE FAMILY.
WHAT MATTERS IN ANY SOCIETY IS
THE INTERVENING INSTITUTIONS
BETWEEN THE INDIVIDUAL AND THE
GOVERNMENT.
YOU MENTION THE FAMILY, HE
MENTIONED THE CHURCH, IT IS ALSO
THINGS LIKE TOWN GOVERNMENT AND
COUNTY GOVERNMENT.
WHEN YOU HAVE SERIOUS
RESOLUTIONS LIKE THE SOVIETS AND
THE FRENCH, THEY ARE BULLISH ON
ALL THOSE.
THE SOVIETS DID GO VERY FAR TO
ABOLISHING THE FAMILY.
THEY'VE GOT SOMETHING SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT, AS WE SEEN IN FLORIDA
DIFFERENT, AS WE SEEN IN FLORID
FLORIDA.
YOU ESSENTIALLY HAVE GOT
GOVERNMENT SOCIAL SERVICES, YOU
GOT GOVERNMENT POLICE AGENTS AT
MULTIPLE LEVELS MONITORING
SOMEONE, AND THEY ARE
ACTUALLY -- THESE THINGS ARE NOT
AS EFFECTIVE AS IN FACT A
FUNCTIONING FAMILY AND LETTING
PARENTS RAISE THEIR CHILDREN, AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING DOCTORS
DETERMINE THAT YOUR 7-YEAR-OLD
IS GOING THROUGH BIT OF A PHASE,
SO LET HIM GET TRANSITIONING TO
A GIRL.
THEY ARE AT WAR WITH ALL THE
INTERVENING AGENCIES BETWEEN
CENTRALIZED POWER AND THE
INDIVIDUAL.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT AN